[Music]
it's the economy stupid has been a
shorthand for political truth for
decades but there are suggestions that
in some people's eyes maybe vote for
brexit maybe the increasing support for
a more leftist Labour Party suggests
that growth in the purest sense might be
sacrificed for social change and social
transformation so has the economy become
less important in politics are we
turning to more radical goals that maybe
don't necessarily put the economy first
and foremost well we're going to find
out more about all of those questions in
just a few moments to do that we have an
immensely distinguished panel with us
today on my left is Vince Cable who is
of course the leader of the Liberal
Democrats he was served in the coalition
cabinet as business secretary and has a
very long and distinguished political
career as indeed does Liz trust Liz is
the chief secretary to the Treasury
she was also I think the first female
Lord Chancellor and justice secretary
and Richard Bergen is shadow justice
secretary in the current labour shadow
cabinet and he is amongst other things
particularly interested in the concepts
organ or concept the reality of legal
aid and the way in which that has been
reduced in recent years so that may well
come in to some of the things we want to
say I'm going to start by asking all of
our panel to say a few words on the
question of whether or not it is true
that the politics that we're now in do
seem to value radical transformational
socialist change over a purely economic
idea of growth Vince Cable what do you
think well I don't think that's what
people are reaching for but there
certainly is a big change from what I
always identified as conventional
politics in the UK and elsewhere and I
thought the conventional view I thought
was captured in Gordon Brown's budgets
if you remember 1012 years ago and he
would announce we just had the 58th
month of uninterrupted growth and
he would cheer and the public would
approve that was the metric by which a
government was judged and seemingly
correctly and indeed rewarded
politically and there were parallels in
the United States with with Clinton's
argument with the bushes Germany you
know Gerhard schröder then Merkel it was
all about competence and something has
now drastically changed and the question
is has it changed because people have
discovered other values I think probably
not although it appears so religion
culture these issues have become more
dominant or is it that people have
reacted to economic failure by looking
at at other at other things and I think
it is the latter and the crucial event
was 2008 the collapse of the banking
system a fall in our economy of I think
5% something it never happened before
since the second world war had a massive
impact on people's living standards on
the ability of government to deliver
services it happened here it happened
across the continent in the United
States and in many other places and I
think partly out of anger and
frustration after a time lag you've had
other kinds of popular politics coming
up and in the United States it's been a
combination of religious fundamentalism
and the kind of nativist politics that
trump is so successfully exploited here
it's brexit in germany it's sort of
anti-muslim anti-immigrant same in
france so we're getting these new
strains of politics coming in but i
think it is a reaction to perceived
economic failure and i think we will see
the proof of this in the next few years
because if Trump fails to deliver
people's living standards don't improve
in the United States if the wages of
American workers continue to stagnate or
fall I suspect they will turn against
him
and the test of populism will be whether
it does meet people's expectations about
living standards now that you could say
that's a sort of crudely economic view
and clearly other values do matter and
I'd like them to matter but I don't
think we should get carried away I'll
just take two examples I mean I would
like to feel that our politics is
becoming a bit greener we're becoming a
bit more environmentally aware climate
emergencies all those things but we've
had a couple of salutary warnings in the
last few months about what happens if
politicians get too carried away Macross
carbon tax resulted in the yellow vests
protest in part the Australian Labor
Party was widely tipped to win the
general election failed to do so at
least in part as a reaction against what
run doubtedly progressive green politics
and so although we've got to I mean I
somebody was on the center-left I would
describe myself as we've got to be alert
to issues around inequality environment
and so on I think we shouldn't get too
far ahead of public opinion where the
new politics is partly a reflection of
the anger that people have felt because
of economic failure Vince thank you very
much for setting out those thoughts at
Curtin straight to you
Richard Burgin obviously sitting in the
in the Shadow Cabinet do you think it's
fair to say that a new more radical
politics on left which many would argue
with Corbin Shadow Cabinet encompasses
is one that has downplayed economics in
terms of much more social radicalism
well I think that in the Labour Party
since Jeremy Corbyn became elected he's
made a central plank
along with the Shadow Chancellor John
MacDonald central plank of his politics
a clear anti austerity politics actually
Jeremy became leader of the Labour Party
on the basis that labour members and
supporters and affiliated trade unions
wanted a very hard very clear opposition
to austerity so in opposition to
austerity a politics for yes economic
growth but
more equally was the very center of his
prospectus and so therefore it's not the
case in my view that Jeremy or Labour
have downplayed the economic aspect but
in terms of the title of this debate and
discussion today a duty is a bit of a
false choice to pose social change
against economic growth whatever label
members of the public put on it I think
most people actually want both
they bought social change in other words
a better society and they also want
economic growth or to be more particular
rather economic change sort of economic
injustice in our society of course
effects people's levels of stress it
affects people's enjoyment of their work
and their day-to-day lives it affects
people's relationship it affects
people's health as well as so many
studies show but I think what people
aren't pursuing is really growth for
growth's sake and a book that finally to
get around to reading in the recess
amongst many others is the book about
donut economics she calls it by kate ray
worth and i think she puts it very
interestingly in there kate says that
humanity's 21st century challenge is to
meet the needs of all within the means
of the planet and when look at the
diagram that she drew up it really
doesn't make sense doesn't it if people
don't have enough and that includes by
the way a political voice housing health
and education and the rest of it they
fall inside the hole but if the economy
grows for the sake of growth in of
itself and isn't checked or regulated or
looked at and you spill over into
damaging that which we depend upon all
of us ant you manatee and the other
species and the globe which is our
environment so people want richer lives
that's intrinsically linked to the
economy and I don't think we can use the
term economy in a neutral sense what it
when we talk about economic growth we've
got to ask ourselves the question of
ownership in distribution what do we
mean by the economy and when growth
takes place who enjoys the fruits of
that growth because in recent decades do
to untrammeled neoliberal economics more
and more the benefits of that growth
have gone to the very richest people
both in our country but also globally as
well so people do want richer large so I
we need to start looking at trying to
reduce the amount of time that people's
day-to-day work or the working week
takes up the proliferation of zeros
contract it's right across right right
across the economic spectrum actually
even those who are relatively well-off
have their own stresses when it comes to
living standards when it comes to Social
Welfare no answer and on this really the
green new deal as proposed by AOC in the
United States and also by Rebecca on
Bell in the Labor Party here is an
important part of this debate but I
suppose I'll finish really with this
quote which i think is very helpful to
understanding this debate and the way I
think is for nuts by the respected
economists from Latin American forum
Ecuadorian President Rafael Correa who
said the great challenge facing Humanity
in the 21st century is to achieve the
supremacy of human beings over capital
with societies dominating markets not
markets dominating societies
you